[Applause]
we should be asking ourselves a bigger
question about the weaponization of the
Department of Justice when I'm president
the first thing I'll do is fire mer
Garland second thing I'll do fire
Christopher Ray because we need Lady
Justice to wear a
blindfold without that no one has
confidence in our justice system 177% of
Republicans have confidence in our
department of justice here's why we keep
seeing not only the weaponization of the
Department of Justice against political
opponents but also against parents who
show up at school board meetings they're
called under this DJ they're called
domestic
terrorist all right joining us now
Senator Tim Scott senator from the great
state of South Carolina how are you my
friend I'm doing really well glad to see
Lindsay's not here for you that thank
God that's true um you're on the stage
tonight how did you feel I felt really
good I felt like I wanted to have a
conversation an adult conversation about
why America can do for anyone what she's
done for me we need to focus on
restoring hope creating opportunities
and protecting America we didn't spend
enough time talking about the challenge
we have at our Southern border we didn't
talking long enough about the challenges
that we have with China it's not the
strength of China it's the weakness of
Biden that's the problem that we face as
a nation we need to dig into some of the
most important consequential issues
facing the American people and not have
a food fight on the stage you know I one
of the things that stood out to me is a
point that I often make that on average
the average American household is paying
nearly $10,000 more for the same items
that they were paying When Donald Trump
left office uh on January What 20th of
of you're 100% right you know 2021 so my
point is and then you have 61% of
Americans living paycheck to paycheck
then you have 50 $4,000 average American
debt how do you climb out from under
that or Bare Necessities people throwing
it on their credit card that is real
suffering and it's all a lot of it
self-induced because of Biden's energy
and economic policy absolutely number
one we have to know that energy security
is National Security but it's also one
of the parts of my 10 million new jobs
made in America plan where we could have
3 million new jobs in the energy sector
America be the leading country on Earth
if we had a president who believed in
our national energy resources if we had
that we would rise to the top because we
have more energy when you add oil gas
and coal listen Africa India are going
to continue to see the carbon footprint
explode because they have tons and tons
of people living in poverty why not use
our resources to meet their needs and
create gas is going back up to $4 a
gallon 11mth high okay 11mon high and
Donald Trump and his years as president
it never went above $3 a gallon never
reached $3 a gallon in December of 2020
in South Carolina the gas price was
a199 those are called the good old days
right those are the good old days good
days we can get them back though we have
to have a president who believes in our
own energy resources okay so you talked
about firing director Ray you talked
about Merck Garland and getting rid of
him he said we'll get rid of no IRS
agents we'll hire them for the Border
absolutely okay now do you believe that
our department of justice and our FBI
have been politicized and weaponized
what are the main reason you would fire
them 100% they have been weaponized we
know now that lady Justice no longer can
find the blindfold when you watch what
this department of justice has done
against political opponents you would
consider that unethical and immoral when
you think about what a stun to parents
just showing up and saying I want my
child educated not indoctrinated you
would call this Department of Justice
immoral when you see a SWAT team show up
at a pro-life activist home with guns
drawn you'd call that immoral
irresponsible and unacceptable what we
know as Americans we must trust our
department of justice it is unamerican
and unacceptable to see what Joe Biden
mayor Garland and Christopher Ray has
done to the doj and most importantly to
the American people's confidence in the
Department of Justice by the way I won't
admit publicly that when we had a
throwing contest at the Town Hall that
you threw further than me that's not
that's just not going to come out of my
mouth absolutely not we'll keep it a
secret Senator always good to see you my
friend thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else